[Applaudissements]
j'arrive à gérer le temps de changer je
suis arrivé à la bombe vient de finir la
chronique j'avais un polo qui avait une
marque ça fait un petit moment que
fédérer et loches
j'ai mis un petit crocodile ne veut pas
dans vos pas de marque jamais terni les
salles comme un pape aussi mais je
n'aurais pas rater le tournoi
ah ouais un jeune homme est alors il va
très bien et je peux pas aller tuer tout
un peuple chinois pour un petit peu
chauffé la salle c'est les 24 arte
laissé 24 ans teyssen résumé heure par
heure et en vitesse de ce qui s'est
passé dans le monde froid et obscur de
la télé c'est énorme
à 8h30 ce matin l'avocat robert bourgi
est revenu sur son clash avec françois
fillon c'est du sérieux même booba tests
que j'ai réalisé qu'on a eu à sa fin
denis qu'est françois fillon ah oui pas
mal
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce que ça veut dire [ __ ] ans
cofinancé c'est mieux que le cube oui
mais non mais attendez piqué en soi
fillon c'était avec l'histoire des
costumes je vais y revenir le mauvais
jamais été autant pro dans sa mini sur
france 5 les animateurs de la
quotidienne ont reçu une question d'une
téléspectatrice qui donne un endroit
particulier question de mireille de mon
froc de sa maison new delhi très vite
j'ai accroché centraux 17h donné la
preuve que cyril féraud devait aller
voir l'ophtalmo d'urgence impasse y voit
des filles partout maintenant compter le
centre le savoir aussi la branche de
sélection avec bérengère stéphanie et
bref ans à 18 ans on a été témoin d'un
drame du quotidien puisque deux enfants
se sont retrouvés prisonniers dans le
nez de gilles verdez je m'excuse à 19
heures à damas tenter le défi de marcher
sur une oeuvre sans le casser 1-0
bourgneuf
messi fait publiquement
jadore jadore jadore jadore pouvoir il a
marché sur l'oeuf sans casser des oeufs
c'est possible si on prend bien le
centre mais je vais essayer demain ça 3
la lettre indique jean-michel à nous y
arrivons à un stand et lettre d' excuses
avant ça j'ai maté qu'aime le nouveau
prime dit jacques martin de ouarzazate
little big star attention les copains ça
y est il est ouvert le centre de
formation à la relève un ça pousse
derrière à l'égaler jeunes sont des gens
casting
cyril vous vous êtes régalés face à tous
ces jeunes talents en prime sur ces 8
vous avez qu'un seul mot à la bouche
énorme vous l'avez utilisé plus de fois
qu'ils rendent une soirée quand lui faut
qu'en huit ans avec jean michaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle mord mission
et c'est ou non c'est non c'est énorme
ce que tu fais vraiment c'est énorme
mais comme à l'école des fans ce qui est
le plus beau c'est que les parents font
le déplacement pour soutenir les enfants
ça offert des vrais bons moments à cyril
en plateau enfin quasiment quoi arriver
là papa maman le nom jour là pour
apporter des vraies infos de notre série
noire suit flinguer de lombers à tabit
au mot chéri à nice à nice j'adore il
fait toujours beau lapin aéroports donné
celui est totalement bloquée c'est
toujours cool du monde entier étaient
présents sur le plateau l'occasion pour
ces rites de montrer ses progrès en
anglais irna ao dai ichi
voilà quarante deux ans né à 39 euros ce
qui cause ce qui se conçoit bien que les
enfants s'ils ont beaucoup de respect
pour notre syrie nous même quand il pose
une question chouïan idiote il le
souligne pas il passe à autre chose mais
quand tu fais ton derrière une caméra
gd rétro en fait et le reste pour sa
part répété ça a été pas suivi de damgan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment un poil à gratter un poil
à gratter
je suis dans un bon jour ce que je
n'arrive pas à comprendre je regarde
notre émission qu'est ce que c'est la
télé ces deux là qu'est né sait que de
la télé j'adore mais sur quel à plat
comme on jamais la télé c'est que de la
ba oui mais si je retournais pas bien ça
mais parce qu'on entend ça me rassure
merci mais la tête à tête un poil à
gratter
j'ai vu des trucs ouais je passe un week
end au footing est-africaine de marc
bull j'ai fini un puzzle la tour eiffel
chacun des grands portails comme tous
les jeunes qui le regarde simplement
j'ai plein de choses déjà une personne
qui a hyper peur des poissons ça peut
arriver d'avoir peur des poissons à tout
le monde a vu phobie bizarre seul
problème et les poissonniers
[Rires]
ils ont aussi suivi une personne savait
qu'il vient en aide aux personnes âgées
qui les aide à domicile c'est mignon
sauf que la personne âgée déteste cette
pauvre dame elle commence par limité
dans son dos prennent ces médicaments
mais ça limite le risque d'erreur parce
que parfois on a des patients qui sont
victimes d'une surdose
elles vont assigner devant les caméras
que parfois il ya des bons moments mais
là encore tatie danielle elle rumine
interview si nos patients se confient
régulièrement et voilà alors parfois on
le remonte le moral parfois on rigole
avec journée pour cette jeune fille
sylvie ambiance en tout le temps et on
travaille ensemble tout le temps donc
activement voilà mais ça se passe bien
non
ensuite pendant une vente à domicile on
a trouvé le couple qui s'offre un nouvel
aspirateur c'est un bon moment sauf
qu'au moment de trinquer on sent que le
mari n'est pas bien du chèque un bonheur
à plus de 2000 euros cessionnaire ils
vont se faciliter la vie
j'ignore public qui s'est éclaté pendant
cette donne justement un indice est la
plus jeune à avoir de recettes
on va faire donc dès demain matin il ya
une sorte de tarte quant aux visiteuses
forme d'hémisphère
un peu plus j'ai pris des nouvelles
d'une personne qu'on aime beaucoup ici
c'est marie colmant
ah oui enfin fo elle va bien on l'avait
nord grand portage elle a changé de
coupe mondiale aussi qu'il me dit par
sms
il est très bon vraiment ils excellent
limoux nuit dans le dernier camping 3
tient justement jugnot me demandais
comment intégrer l'émission d'anne rice
est vrai je m'en rappellerai là il a
réussi
ouais ça si les idées là il est lent on
embrasse alors n'hésite pas à la rue sur
la chronique de camille qu'en général
ils rien écrit vous promets basque est
ce que je veux qu'à me fais comme s'il
n'était pas là c'est complet depuis tout
à l'heure tu te fais des sites fait
comme ça à exagérer ce vrai coup de
pouce de gens me on va chez les jeunes
et aussi à passer une case des diamants
poteau du skate park avec qui je fais
des kick flip à 180 degrés qui anime
tous les soirs sur france 3 des chiffres
et des lettres c'est lolo tony hawk
romejko lolo romejko qui a décidé de
casser les codes d'aujourd'hui madame en
déchiffrer des deux c'est un peu ric rac
l'ue a décidé de tout péter c'est un
vrai déglingo regarder chaque jour
depuis maintenant 60 ans il arrive sur
ce plateau avec la même entrée voilà de
ce côté là mais aujourd'hui la péter
plomb dans l'indifférence la plus totale
je vous rassure bien sûr
m côté météo la camisole et on va
aborder aussi sur france 3 dans huit
chances pour tout gagner cette fois la
candidate nous a bien fait comprendre
qu'elle n'est pas ravie d'avoir joué
quatre heures pour gagner un radio
réveil il y tout ce qui me reconnaîtront
voilà j'ai la game moi mes enfants
lauriers lucas et mon mari qui
m'accompagne souvent dans mes galères
[Musique]
dans cela philippe ferro a voulu faire
une vanne à une drh
mais la candidate eux rentrent pas dans
le délire elle est très premier degré
sur les régions nord cette ville
bérengère aussi vous êtes allé non jean
alesi un jour en hauteur un jour c'est
exceptionnel comme il h dans la vie
faire un petit contrôle dans une
entreprise en fleurs des enchères dans
mon secteur
c'est pas son secteur premier degré mais
c'est venu par son secteur
on sait que dans mon secteur
non c'est pas sur cette mignonne et
millsap l'odéon va pas lui faire prendre
un bide mais ca plonge 148
bon j'ai aussi regardé et et du monde
entier à j'adore le soya quoique am 30
40 pays dans le monde
j'ai tout regardé mes gars et
franchement la télé hongroise niveau
organisation pour la retransmission des
discours des politiques qui sont au top
pense à tout caméra lumière sont il
manque qu'une chose les semelles
antidérapantes
[Musique]
non
revenir pour voir le tard bas de l'année
c'est ce monsieur regarder il fait chaud
ce mari il ya vingt ans à tf1 nous
emmener à la découverte des routes
réouverte de la zad les analystes on
peut voir libérée vous ne voyez pas au
duplex au bord des terrains
sa seule balle en vous parlant le doré
garder le ballon et ajuste à 6 ans
sortent et depuis qu'il a arrêté les
amours tech s'est mis à la muscu on l'a
revu dans un jt texte
[Musique]
on peut pas avoir la chute va parce
qu'elle nous fait mal on grille je crois
elle nous fait une chute à la capucine
adam regardons eu c'est vrai regardez à
l'essai de la piscine mais ça va bien
elle va bien on n'a pas d'états d'âme
c'est bon j'adore le maquis comme ça va
très bien on l'a eu au téléphone
c'est bon tout va bien bon j'ai maté
rouge sur nrj12 frecon j'ai passé un
week-end de merde ne passe pas là
[Applaudissements]
alors ils vont faire je le rejoigne
c'était une émission que présenter
maintenant voyez la gouverne du verrou
tant que ça fait très cher à produire
note diffusée est tournée mais faut pas
le réduire à ça dans ma carrière sur les
chats sur tf1 vous avez qu'ils ont tous
chanté goldman alors j'ai gagné ça fait
beaucoup parler ça fait couler beaucoup
ça c'est cool les deux noms il ya tout
le monde a chanté notamment à venir qui
nous a montré qu'on pouvait se prendre
un poteau dans la gueule mais avec
classe où tout en soulignant
[Musique]
poursuit de manière quasi muet et
regarder aussi tient sur destination
eurovision le grand concours regarder
qui s'est joué
est ce qu'on a dans la tête de cette
juliette et eric raoult pas là mais je
vous jure que c'est vrai j'ai eu plein
de textos et plein d'autres sur twitter
tombe de juliette hanouna oui j'ai passé
3 4 gucci voilà c'est vrai gillett on
peut pas revoir à venir on peut pas
revoir mais vous avez vu comme c'est un
rôle direct comme ça non non c'est sûr
qu'à n'y avait peut-être pas de la glace
quelque chose lui il est là pour pro il
est toujours problème
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi ya eu quand on encore un peu de
temps et toujours pour le talent des
basses week-end j'étais corpo j'ai
regardé c'est the voice est vrai les
gars les stars étaient pas que dans le
jury regard des walis le début de
l'émission
on a fait la connaissance de l'enfant de
stars entre lionel richie est un des
jurés de d'affaires conclut gelé une des
candidates à chanter du pic aussi les
petits plaisirs on aime bien on a
remplacé sa voix par une cover internet
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup moins qu'à
les voir et on s'y croirait et vous avez
parlé plus obispo qu'à pleurer pour
cette première on s'est procuré les
roches de l'émission avant le montage au
déconner les vraies raisons de ses
larmes
[Musique]
n'importe quoi
voir
vous avez coup de grâce pour pascal
obispo c'est quand il a appris sa fougue
et combien ça j'aime bien ça gagne sur
tf1 l'animateur pourra j'avais douze
mille euros par épisode
12000 euros par émission et besoin de
tourner cinq par jour
ouais ouais moi j'adorais regarder mais
c'est pas vrai vous étiez pas dans un
karaoké j'ai regardé la redif
aujourd'hui attention il est à 10 noeuds
3,6 me à la mi temps rennes ou moi on
sait tous on voit tout à vous qu'est-ce
qu'on a d'autres noms de b bon alors là
on finit à vraiment c foot quoi c'est
choquant alors là c'est là la femme en
est donc à se monter des sportifs open
de champagne on n'y va jamais chez les
ja on voit tout regarder oui j'ai
regardé alors vous savez peut-être pas
mais l'équipe la chaîne l'équipe s'est
offert quand même les droits de la
course des championnats d'europe
d'enduro pour la modique somme du
commerce qu'une pièce de deux euros
une compacte avec des motards du monde
entier mais un journaliste qui lui ne
parle pas les langues étrangères dès sa
première interview on s'est rendu compte
que son apprennent serait c'est long en
colère le lieu on rappelle du
championnat président d'avoir peut-être
quelques informations de ce côté de
l'équipe juste sera pas la colère avec
cette perte de 102
réaliste dit je vais tenter l'anglais
mais vu son niveau il s'arrête au milieu
des questions carrément y compris fo pas
la peine
just ouais ouais ouais mais comme il
comprend pas d'en tuer l'espagnol les
quoi ils essaient de parler français
pour l'aider mais tu comprends autant
que quand jean mito donne son avis sur
le volet et papa comment ça s'est passé
déjà le ravitaillement il comment ça se
passe ce début de course manhattan oui
là comme chef maï normale tant qu'il
y'aura cohérence la course de l'autre
que la moto et s'il a pu passer
d'apprendre
colas le pire coaché y verra des
français la moto ici le meilleur
merci elle est d'abord voici le maître
qui simule sa mort pour voir comment son
chien allait s'y prendre pour le sauver
c'est beau c'est qu'il a faim la donne
le magic a fait une croix des changes où
va aller là vous allez vous allez
arrêter de dire oh bah on se dira que sa
vision tél
j'ai des jardineries truc en plus avons
voulu bien faire mais ça je veux le
revoir quelques mois le bac a une idée
en plus des morts
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]